metagenomics is as we know is a way to
study microorganisms in their natural
and we don't
by exploring the species of richness and
by investigating the functional roles of
these microbial communities and what
they play
and the role that they play in many
areas that related to human health and
human disease in our general well-being
so in this webinar you will learn about
the upcoming omics Logics metagenomics
program and these programs as we know
and as we have been presenting are
designed to be rewarding to students
researchers faculties and citizen
scientists and etc etc many people who
are generally interested in
understanding omics analysis to several
different omics data profiles the
program in general will cover main
aspects of metagenomic sequencing the
analysis of 16s rrna sequencing data and
the other aspects of
microbiology this is using
bioinformatics and downstream analysis
of metagenomic sequencing outputs using
R and Python and using code free
platform
Etc using the turbo bio info
and you will be uh
familiar in metagenomics
data analysis and metagenomic sequencing
generally analysis in general and you'll
be able to conduct independent projects
and do independent analysis and you will
be equipped to handle data from you know
publicly available resources
somebody mute
yes thank you am I audible still
yes sir you're audible I think my
screens are gone
okay wait a second the screenshot is
creating some problems
okay I think I should be uh you should
be able to see my screen
yes sir it's visible that's perfect so I
was talking to you about uh how
generally this program will acute acute
participants like you to be able to
conduct independent projects using
metagenomic sequence analysis data and
you will also be able to handle and find
data from publicly available resources
in public domain and you can also learn
from high impact biomedical Publications
on the microbiome the kind of analysis
that they perform and what are they
actually referring to when they are
talking about the diversity and that
that also leads to dysbiosis and
symbiosis of microbial population in
relationship to the phenotypical
characteristics of the sample are under
different biological conditions with
which the samples are actually recorded
or referred
so as in all of our Amex logic training
program we will use online sessions we
will use asynchronous sessions we will
use self-guided study materials and we
will use several different example
projects that uh that will help you get
a effective understanding and good
experience of understanding the concepts
related to the metagenomics sequence
analysis and metagenomics data analysis
so let's dive into this session with the
focus on metagenomics focusing mostly on
the bioinformatics part related to the
analysis of the sequencing data so
before we begin let's see
and how are the different areas with
which we can relate the metagenomics
data and metagenomics information too
and ask important questions about these
microbial communities and uh
um and also review couple of studies
that were used to characterize
microbiota from different resources
so the connection between disease and
microorganisms has been established in
the 1800s and we already know that
towards the end of the 19th century we
have several established laboratory
methods for growing microorganisms in
lab culture right and these
developed methods of growing these
organisms in laboratory
Trace system with staining and other
methods and helps us understand their
characteristics and help us understand
their relationship to our diseases and
path of pathogenicity in gender
right and these studies in the earlier
stages of understanding the
microorganisms uh helps us or they
actually provided us important
information about these bacteria or
these microbes and their function in
isolation but however it was soon
apparent and we already found out that
most of these microbial organisms live
in a Complex Community today we know
that these microorganisms or we called
them as microbiota that make up the
human microbiome or not just unicellular
organisms living alongside each other
but instead they form highly regulated
highly structural and highly
functionally organized communities that
are
skin attached to several different
organs and um they collaborate with the
organs and they contribute to the
ecological and they contribute to the
stability and well-being of the tissues
and of the organism that they are found
part of
so uh to give an estimate the human
microbiota biota is estimated to be
around 10 to the power 13 or 14 of
microbial cells and they roughly
translate into one is to one ratio of
microbial cells to human cells uh ratio
number and these microbes they form
distinct communities and they are
interconnected to maintain their
Community the stability of these
communities in their own environment is
a fascinating study and the researches
that are of that helps us understand
these stabilities and the effort that
these microbes putting to maintain the
stabilities are fascinating and they
give us several insights into how these
stable environment related to our
well-being and our reaction to different
disease States and different
pathogenicity
and we already know that and we already
also see that bacteria can communicate
with each other by producing detecting
and responding to several small
diffusable signal molecules the fencing
of these signal molecules are also
involved in the virulence and the
pathogenic potential of the bacteria and
is therefore an important factor in
understanding and controlling bacterial
infection in general
so inside and alongside each of this
community there is a balance of bacteria
fungi and viruses that control species
abundance and activity so in each of
this environment each one of these
microorganisms carry important
functional properties in genes that
contain genomic information right we can
study the genomic
um data of these microorganisms to
understand the properties of the genes
and to understand the functional
importance of these microorganisms in
their environment these properties and
the genomic information about these
microorganisms have been of a growing
interest to the scientific community and
it has already resulted in over 80 000
Publications in Tokyo or and it's still
growing and the majority of these
Studies have actually focused on
intestinal microbiome and several other
areas of microbial
um
population and studies are also coming
into uh
coming into their research or coming
into the height
so however since 1990s microbiome
studies are actually significantly
Advanced to to several major initiatives
like the metagenomics of human
intestinal tract and human microbiome
project and huge studies several such
Studies have made possible through the
advances of advances in metagenamic
sequencing in general and these
sequencing which are as a result of
which came as a result of development in
high throughput sequencing efforts or
next Generation sequencing effort have
actually made it possible that there is
a there is an ever increasing amount or
ever increasing availability of the data
uh that can easily pour into several of
the derived data that several of the
direct projects and research that that
are fueled by the existence of such uh
biological data
so as a result of these studies skin
lung gut and even brain microbiota are
starting are starting to be getting
characterized and their relationship
with our well-being and the general
their involvement in
um in in maintaining balance between
General
symbiosis general biosis of our
microbial Community are constantly being
explored and related to
so today we know that the endogenous
human microbial communities contributes
to critical metabolic critical
physiological and immunological
functions and these are all functions
that include differentiation and
maturations of the immune system and
sometimes they include food digestion
and nutrition for
additional elements and they also
include metabolic regulation and control
of the fat storage or energy storage and
they are also involved in processing and
detoxification of environmental
chemicals and we also know from acne and
other related studies they are involved
in maintaining skin and mucosar barrier
function
and more
relations are more
um
key connections are establishing or
getting established in the development
and regulation of the immune system
or inflammatory and anti-inflammatory
substances are also getting actively
studied on so prevention and invasion of
invasion of disease promoting
microorganisms and and the general
colonization resistance and general
resistance of
um of
advantages microbes to this this is
promoting microorganisms are also be
actively explored
so the term metagenomics covers all of
these studies and refers to both the
research technique and also the research
field so the field can be defined as the
genomic analysis of the microbial DNA
from these environmental communities
that we discussed on and the tools that
used to study these analysis
um
enable us to understand or enable us to
make a population analysis of previously
unknown microbes or previously
unculturable or uncharacterized microbes
are bacteria in general this is very
very important in the current scenario
because only around one to two
percentage of the bacteria can be
cultured and grown and studied in the
laboratory and the ability to identify
these microbes without a priority
knowledge of what the sample contains is
actually opening new doors into the
research areas like ecology like
virology microbiology environmental
science and biomedical research
etc etc the sequencing based examination
of the metagenome has become an
extremely powerful tool for
understanding their diversity and their
effects in several of these research
areas that I just listed on and has
become very useful tool in generating
novel hypothesis that relate it's this
metagenome to several of these research
areas
so this sequencing can actually applied
to any culture free Environmental
population as well as it can be applied
to any general detailed extraction of
microorganisms
that can be characterized with or
without culturing in labs and often
often times in order to gain a complete
understanding of these Selected Few
microorganisms these techniques are
combined first a detailed or an
exploratory metagenomics approach has
been applied to some to culture freeze
sample and then from these Selected Few
microorganisms are actually grown in the
laboratory culture to explore and to
verify the hypothesis that we generate
from the metagenomic sequencing or this
culture free sequence intents
so many of these questions are being
answered as I mentioned using the uh
using the tools such as using the very
important tool that is next Generation
sequencing which focuses on either
sequencing the whole genome or the whole
or it can focus on uh sequencing
selected Gene like 16 as rrna or 18 is
rrna of the microbes or sometimes
selected portions of these genes of the
microbes right and each and in uh and in
performing uh these different sequencing
methods we will focus on we are going to
focus on answering or addressing several
important uh several uh different key
questions and uh that will help us
generate hypothesis related to the data
related to the biological condition of
the samples okay
so in general when we look or when we
discuss about these different
Technologies and these different methods
that are used to characterize
metagenomics and microbial populations
we have a shotgun metagenomics and we
have a 16s metagenomics or Amplified
frequency methods while the shotgun
metagenomics or transcriptomics meta
transcriptomics will focus on
understanding all of the genes or the
whole genome of the microbes and this
can help us in analyzing for example
um the general assembly with the help of
the general genome assembly of these
several different microbes we can get
key insights into their functional
contribution in maintaining the
maintaining the balance and in helping
us with the um
with the processing of the metabolites
we can also
the prediction of the genes across
to be a key factor or key player in
maintaining these meta and maintaining
this and metabolism and their
processing levels so while shotgun
metagenomics and transcriptomics will
address at the functional level of the
microbial population in addition to
sometimes
um in addition to giving us an estimate
of these microbial population more
um
what to say uh
more reliable methods in in estimating
the abundance level of these several
these
different taxonomic level can be
performed using 16s amplicon
metagenomics right these 16s sequencing
is is a technique that is widely used to
study a microbiome directly in its
environment and this will focus on
either as I already mentioned 16s are
are 18s ribosomal RNA that has to be
Amplified using PCR amplification method
before getting Quantified and matched
onto the database of known 16s rrna
sequences so these sequences
contain hyper variable regions and
variable regions that provide species
specific signature sequences that are
extremely useful and are used to
identify bacteria and their taxonomic
ranks how are these how are they
generally performed
um
so they are actually in addition to
sequencing uh these PCR Amplified reads
or PCR Amplified uh
um shared products of these 16s rrna
Gene uh we pull them or we generally
cluster them in group of closely related
individuals as defined by their
taxonomic uh Identity or taxonomic or
sequential Identity or sequential
similarities right these consensus
sequences are actually defined as
operational taxonomical taxonomic units
and their abundance is actually
characterized and Quantified for
different samples
are no longer in use as we have asbs
because asvs can be
can be a general term that can take
anywhere between 95 percentage of the
sequence identity to 99 percentage
otus are restricted in then in the
amount of identity that are used to
define how two sequences are related to
each other that is why okay it's not the
case that it is not generally in use it
is still in use but in order to have a
very generic application of these
sequential identity and their
relationship to identifying key
taxonomic uh ranks we are referring to
asps okay
foreign
so they can be classified or they can be
clustered using general clustering
approaches that will cluster these reads
based on their percentage of identity
liposite identity level that we are
defining while defining the amount of uh
while defining the
capsynomic units that we want to
characterize so we were discussing that
these taxonomic units are are actually
uh
uh
taxonomic uh
organization in terms of uh kingdom
phylum class uh genus etc etc so these
These otus are the one uh that are
identified as specific species of genus
or phyla of bacteria and they are the
one that are that will get characterized
that are that we get Quantified along uh
among different samples yeah
so once this quantification is performed
as I mentioned they are identified to be
part of these specific ranks
uh these specific ranks using special uh
using space how much information for
domains of bacteria archae and bacteria
and etc etc right it is primarily based
on uh the phytogenes of the subunits of
rrna and uh thank you ramakumar and yeah
um subunits of the 16s are radius and
their relationship to the taxonomic
lines that we already discussed about so
in addition to this we also have birobe
which refers to one part of microbiome
that constitutes all of the organisms
um are that contributes to uh all of the
viruses that might inhibit that might
inhabit us right
um
so characterizing the the biome of
mammalian
mammalian samples are our samples and
their relationship to Crossing disease
is also extremely important because
sometimes these viruses can be carrier
for several other uh they are also
implicated in being carrier to uh
oncology related uh issues and um
yeah oncology uh oncological
implications and several tumor
progression are also be implicated to
these abundance levels of specific
viruses